IMBECILES.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
FOR MORE THAN A YEAR NOW, WE
HAVE BEEN DOCUMENTING HOW THE
DEMOCRATS, WORKING IN TANDEM
WITH FAR LEFT SMEAR SQUAD, HAVE
SET ABOUT TO STIFLE CONSERVATIVE
SPEECH.
NOW THESE FOLKS THINK OF
THEMSELVES AS ROUGH AND TUMBLE,
KIND OF FOOTBALL PLAYERS, BUT
THERE ULTIMATELY BLINDED BY THE
BRIGHT LIGHTS.
CAMPAIGNS OF FULL OUTRAGE HAVE
STOKED UP SOCIAL MEDIA.
THEY WHIP UP THEIR FRENZIED
FOLLOWERS, AND THEN THAT
JUSTIFIES THEIR TRAMPLING OF THE
FREE-SPEECH RIGHTS OF OTHERS.
EVERYONE IS ALL UPSET.
BUT THEY'VE NEVER TRIED THEIR
LITTLE CHARADE ON SOMEONE LIKE
CANDACE OWENS BEFORE.
SHE ENTERED THEIR HOLY GROUND,
THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE HEARING
BY DEMOCRATS.
OF THE TOPIC?
HATE CRIMES AND THE RISE OF
WHITE NATIONALISM.
>> I RECEIVED WORD ON MY WAY IN
THAT MANY OF THE JOURNALISTS
WERE CONFUSED AS TO WHY I WAS
INVITED, AND NONE OF THEM KNEW
THAT I, MYSELF, WAS A VICTIM OF
A HATE CRIME WHEN I WAS IN
HIGH SCHOOL.
WHITE SUPREMACY, RACISM, WHITE
NATIONALISM, HAVE BECOME NOTHING
MORE THAT ELECTION STRATEGIES.
EVERY FOUR YEARS, THE BLACK
COMMUNITY IS OFFERED HANDOUTS
AND FEAR.
HANDOUTS AND FEAR.
THE ANCESTRY OF BLACK AMERICANS
IS BEING INSULTED EVERY SINGLE
DAY.
I WILL NOT PRETEND TO BE A
VICTIM IN THIS COUNTRY.
I KNOW THAT MAKES MANY PEOPLE ON
THE LEFT UNCOMFORTABLE.
>> Laura: SMOKING.
CONGRESSMAN TED LIEU WAS LYING
IN WAIT FOR MS. OWEN.
AND HELD UP A LITTLE MICROPHONE
RECORDER AND PLAY THIS EDITED
CLIP.
>> ACTUALLY DON'T HAVE ANY
PROBLEMS AT ALL WITH THE WORD
NATIONALISM.
I THINK THE DEFINITION GETS
POISONOUS.
BY ELITIST NOT WANT GLOBALISM
HERE THE FIRST THING PEOPLE
THINK ABOUT, AT LEAST IN
AMERICA, IS HITLER.
BUT IF HITLER WANTED TO MAKE
GERMANY GREAT AND HAVE THINGS ON
WELL, OKAY, FINE.
THE PROBLEM IS HE HAD DREAMS
OUTSIDE OF GERMANY.
HE WANTED TO GLOBALIZE.
>> Laura: THAT WAS HER
GRANDFATHER BEHIND HER, BY THE
WAY.
RATHER THAN ASK HER QUESTIONS,
OR HECK, EVEN CHALLENGE HER
VIEWS ON THE VICTIM BEING
PEDDLED BY THE MEDIA, THE
CONGRESSMAN ATTACKED HER
CHARACTER.
HE DOESN'T HONESTLY BELIEVE THAT
CANDACE OWENS WAS SOMEHOW
EMPATHIZING WITH HITLER, COURSE
HE DOESN'T.
BUT GUESS WHAT?
OWENS REFUSED TO LET THE MOMENT
PASS UNCHALLENGED.
>> WHEN I RESPONDED TO YOU, I DO
NOT BELIEVE THAT WE SHOULD BE
CHARACTERIZING HITLER AS A
NATIONALIST.
HE WAS A HOMICIDAL, PSYCHOPATHIC
MANIAC THAT KILLED HIS OWN
PEOPLE.
A NATIONALIST WOULD NOT KILL
THEIR OWN PEOPLE.
I THINK IT'S PRETTY APPARENT
THAT MR. LIEU BELIEVES BLACK
PEOPLE ARE STUPID AND WILL NOT
PLAY THE FULL CLIP IN ITS
ENTIRETY.
>> IT'S NOT PROPER TO REFER
DISPARAGINGLY TO A MEMBER OF THE
COMMITTEE HERE THE WITNESS WILL
NOT DO THAT AGAIN.
THE WITNESS MAY CONTINUE.
>> SURE, EVEN THOUGH I WAS
CALLED DESPICABLE.
>> THE WITNESS MAY NOT REFER TO
A MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE ASKED
STUPID.
>> I DIDN'T REFER TO HIM I
STUPID, THAT IS NOT WHAT I SAID.
THAT IS NOT WHAT I SAID AT ALL.
YOU DIDN'T LISTEN TO WHAT I SAI
SAID.
MAY I CONTINUE?
>> PLEASE.
>> Laura: [LAUGHS]
CAN YOU IMAGINE?
IF A LIBERAL, AFRICAN-AMERICAN
WOMAN WERE TREATED THIS WAY?
WHAT THEY WOULD DO, IF YOU ARE
SPEAKING HER TRUTH.
FEMINIST ACROSS AMERICA WOULD BE
IN AN ALL-OUT REVOLT.
YOU WOULD HAVE, SAMANTHA BEE
WOULD BE SPLUTTERING ABOUT
MISOGYNY, GILLIBRAND AND WARREN
WOULD HAVE CANDLELIT VISUALS
ACROSS AMERICA.
LET ME BE CRYSTAL CLEAR HERE.
WHAT IS HAPPENING IS AN ALL OUT
ASSAULT ON AMERICA'S FREEDOM OF
CONSCIENCE, FREEDOM OF
EXPRESSION, FREEDOM OF MOVEMENT.
AND IT IS EVEN HAPPENING TO
CHILDREN WHO STEP OUT OF LINE.
LAST NIGHT, WE BROUGHT YOU THE
STORY OF AN 11-YEAR-OLD LITTLE
GIRL, VELMA SCOTTO, WHO WAS
CALLED OUT BY HER TEACHER IN
LONG ISLAND, FOR CHOOSING
DONALD TRUMP AS HER HERO FOR A
SCHOOL REPORT.
AGAIN, IMAGINE THE UPROAR IF
SOME TEACHER ASKED SOME STUDENT
NOT TO WRITE ABOUT BARACK OBAMA
AS HER OR HIS HERO.
AND OF COURSE, MEDIA
LIGHTWEIGHTS USE THE SAME
TACTICS.
>> THE THING THAT IS SO
DISTURBING ABOUT WHAT WILLIAM
BARR IS DOING IS HERE IS YET
ANOTHER PERSON WHO IS TRASHING
THEIR REPUTATION IN THE NAME OF
DONALD TRUMP.
ANOTHER PERSON, MY GOD, WHERE
HAS HE BEEN THE PAST COUPLE OF
YEARS, WILL EXIT THE WHITE HOUSE
SORRY THAT HE HAD TRASHED HIS
REPUTATION FOR DONALD TRUMP.
>> Laura: SCARBOROUGH?
QUESTIONING BILL BARR?
OKAY.
WHAT HE IS IMPLYING THERE IS
THAT HE AND HIS POISONOUS
PANELISTS WILL RELENTLESSLY
MALIGN BILL BARR AND ANYONE ELSE
WHO WORKS FOR OR EVEN SUPPORTS
THE ADMINISTRATION FOR THAT
MATTER.
HIS WORDS ARE THINLY VEILED
THREATS.
THEY ARE A WARNING SHOT, NOT
JUST FOR BARR, BUT FOR ANYONE
EVEN THINKING OF TAKING A JOB
WITH THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
FORMER DHS SECRETARY KRISTIN
NELSON IS ANOTHER TARGET.
YESTERDAY, ALEXANDRA CAUSEY OR
TWEETED FAVORABLY IN RESPONSE
TO SOMEONE WHO WANTS TO PUNISH
NIELSEN, EVEN IF SHE RETURNS TO
PRIVATE LIFE.
SO APPARENTLY IT WASN'T ENOUGH
TO HARASS PEOPLE AT THEIR HOMES
OR IN RESTAURANTS.
NOW FAR LEFT ACTIVIST LAUNCHED
PETITION DRIVES TO PREVENT THESE
FORMER TRUMP STAFFERS FROM
EARNING A LIVING AFTER THEIR
GOVERNMENT SERVICE.
NICE.
WHAT THESE ACTIVISTS ARE SAYING
IS THIS: THE PRICE OF WORKING
FOR TRUMP'S YOU ARE NOW AND
FOREVER UNCLEAN.
AN UNTOUCHABLE.
MY FRIENDS, NO CEO, NO COLLEGE
PRESIDENT, NOR ANY POTENTIAL
EMPLOYER, SHOULD EVER BOW TO
THESE TYPES OF THREATS.
THAT IS WHAT THEY ARE, THREATS.
EVEN ONCE REASONABLE, FAIRLY
REASONABLE DEMOCRATS, ARE NOW
SUPPORTING THIS CAMPAIGN OF
BRANDING THE TRUMP TEAM WITH A
BIG SCARLET LETTER, A BIG T.
>> SHE HAD A BACKGROUND IN CYBER
SECURITY, BUT I THINK THAT IS
NOT WHAT SHE IS GOING TO BE
KNOWN FOR.
IT FRANKLY HAS TO RAISE THE
QUESTION FOR ANYONE WHO IS
OFFERED A CABINET OPPORTUNITY
WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP WHETHER THE
REPUTATION WILL SURVIVE.
>> HE'S GOING TO CONTINUE TO
LOOK FOR PEOPLE THAT COME IN
MANY WAYS, ARE WILLING TO
VIOLATE THEIR OATH OF OFFICE,
WHICH IS TO ENFORCE THE LAW.
THAT MEANS HE IS GOING TO HAVE A
VERY DIFFICULT TIME FINDING GOOD
PEOPLE.
>> Laura: IT'S UNBELIEVABLE.
BUT THAT IS THE GOAL, ISN'T IT?
THE LEFT IS ON INTERESTED IN
ACTUALLY DOING THINGS CALLED
SOLVING PROBLEMS.
IT IS MOVED TO 24/7 CHARACTER
ASSASSINATION OF ANYONE WHO
SUPPORTS HIS POLICIES AND HAS
THE GUTS TO SAY SO.
EVEN LITTLE KIDS, LIKE THAT GIRL
ON LONG ISLAND.
RATHER THAN SAYING, MY FRIENDS,
IN A DEFENSIVE CROUCH WHEN
THEY THREATEN AND DEMONIZE
PATRIOTIC AMERICANS, WE AT
"THE INGRAHAM ANGLE" WILL
CONTINUE TO EXPOSE THE TACTICS,
THE FUNDING OF THESE
ORGANIZATIONS UNDERNEATH ALL OF
IT, AND THEIR ULTIMATE AIM.
AND TOGETHER, I'M EXTREMELY